ya know and welcome to this video
playing I am finger slip no FM I'm sorry
finger slip Cain going for classical
we're aiming for the brayer know i
should play 98 of what to go for that
the AI a routine slips in with Knight a5
plate that so often mmm early thank
arrow hmm I always tend to place your
five-year I'm not quite sure that this
is the right approach but I'm so used to
doing that okay evil interesting as you
try to play against the beep horn that
way no put a 5 well okay
yeah I have a couple of useful moves
ready no he takes it hmm i am not quite
sure what hey White's planets in this
position as he tried you okay midnight
you 3 i'm just probably taking so haha
no is covering this i can go see for now
here why not gaining more space yes he
has to proudly and now i can regroup the
night ii to e6 and over chair for Bishop
h6 also was an option interesting option
which I didn't take maybe I should have
but ok it's not a big deal so might have
form that's not bad if he has to take it
would be excellent for me okay it does
not have to take it but if you feel
somehow inclined to do so again let's go
here
yeah it's in very nice position for
black
very good night down F for more space
and white at some funny pieces it's
still fairly symmetrical though so
though he's not going to break down
break down quickly I would love to play
rook da 1093 but currently there's a
bishop on b6 okay goodnight e7 and then
rock t8 let's do it
uh-huh but now my long diagonal opens up
this is how to how to believe to be good
94 though this is something that he has
gained but still slow should be really
nice for like
okay i have a couple of options I can go
F 3 which is probably quite nice I can't
go f5 couple of interesting moves maybe
just this one if three
yeah I think this is a good one and
queens have six attacking c3 and
attacking f3 I Scott Queen III though
huh this I didn't really I mean I know
it's an easy move but I didn't see it um
yeah I can just take you five ahead we
should be five yeah this is just like
cilantro black I think I mean taking be
four at age three now so
don't don't see move for wider okay well
look T 2 looks good threatening rook
takes e2 yeah I can still take it Queen
age 6 s Queen chicks you want winning
the house check check I don't see amid
right away so let's take the light their
signs okay let's have a look yeah not
sure about this han caido would what I'm
pretty certain of is that that a five is
a is a strange move I think this helps
me quite quite considerably because it
releases the pressure on b5 I think it
was interesting for why to play d5
intending Queenie to Bishop d3 putting
some pressure on the pond I think this
would have been quite a bit better I'm
here I've already quite comfortable I
think play des which and the engine
actually doesn't like it wants to take
twice and immediately put pressure on
the center yeah there is some point to
that if you look at this is the engines
continuation with already clear
advantage for black now I could 95 d 5
it's possible we haven't that my pieces
are already a bit more a bit better
coordinated also note that a 5 is really
weak am in the rook has to defend it and
sometimes after d5 there might be Bishop
b4 yeah it's pretty good
better than what I played even though
the position now is very very
comfortable yeah very very logical play
and now he took it which is hmm yeah
probably how to how to keep this
pollution and this is this is even
better just a ticking c3 not even
playing a 3m yeah why there's a hard
time now how is he defending that pond
if you place this as FF 30 kids in
better than root tea too okay Black is
winning him I mean this is probably good
for me but not winning yeah because of
Queen III moolah that I didn't really
appreciate beforehand after that I don't
have a clear continuation I don't get a
poem back em it's not bad but it's
clearly not the best between f6 amelia
was bad i er no no I'm winning just
winning winning material on chat for
nothing yeah I think it all began with a
5 which doesn't seem to belong into this
position but they didn't exploit it to
the fullest okay i hope you liked it
thanks for watching